foreign
as if you will live forever
live like you will die tomorrow
[Music]
stay away from those people who try to
disparage your Ambitions small minds
will always do that but great minds will
give you a feeling that you too can
become great
[Music]
when you give joy to other people you
get joy in return
when you change your thoughts you change
your world
[Music]
Nature has given us all the pieces
required to achieve exceptional wellness
and health but has left it to us to put
the pieces together
Success is Not final failure is not
fatal
it is the courage to continue that
counts
[Music]
it is better to be original and fail
than to copy and succeed
[Music]
the road to success and the road to
failure are almost exactly the same
success usually comes to those who are
too busy to look for it
develop success from failure
discouragement and failure are two of
the surest Stepping Stones to success
is peace of mind which is the direct
result of the self-satisfaction of
knowing you made the effort to become
the best of what you are capable of
success is getting what you want
happiness is wanting what you get
[Music]
the pessimist sees difficulty in every
opportunity
The Optimist sees opportunity in every
difficulty
don't let yesterday take up too much of
today
you learn more from failure than From
Success don't let failure stop you
failure builds character
[Music]
if you are working on something you
really care about you don't have to be
pushed the vision pulls you
experiences a hard teacher because she
gives the test first the lesson
afterwards
concentrate all your thoughts upon the
work at hand
the sun's rays do not burn until they
are focused
[Music]
either you run the day or the day runs
you
[Music]
I'm a great believer in luck I find the
harder I work the luckier I get
when we strive to become better than we
are everything around us becomes better
too
opportunity is missed by most people
because it is dressed in overalls and
looks like work
setting goals is the first step in
turning the invisible into the visible
he who conquers himself is the mightiest
Warrior
try not to become a man of success
rather become a man of value
one man with courage makes a majority
one secret of success in life is for a
man to be ready for opportunity when it
appears
the successful man will profit from his
mistakes and try again in a different
way
a successful man is one who can lay a
firm foundation with the bricks others
have thrown at him
he is a wise man who does not grieve for
the things which he has not but rejoices
for those which he has
foreign
[Music]
with determination if you're going to go
to bed with satisfaction
education is the most powerful weapon
you can use to change the world
the most difficult thing is the decision
to act the rest is mere tenacity
take the attitude of a student
never be too big to ask questions
never know too much to learn something
new
the elevator to success is out of order
you'll have to use the stairs one step
at a time
be a positive energy trampoline absorb
what you need and rebound more back
work until your bank account looks like
your phone number
life is like a sewer what you get out of
it depends on what you put into it
don't practice until you get it right
practice until you can't get it wrong
May the best day of your past be the
worst day of your future
[Music]
a ship is safe in Harbor but that's not
what ships were made for
a mind that is stretched by a new
experience can never go back to its
former dimensions
somewhere in the world someone is
training when you are not
when you race against him he will win
if opportunity doesn't knock build a
door
we choose to go to the Moon not because
it is easy but because it is hard
there ain't no problem that some other
dude didn't have a thousand years ago
some people think that if their opponent
plays a beautiful game it's okay to lose
I don't you have to be merciless
one day your life will Flash before your
eyes
make sure the show is worth watching
[Music]
education is not the feeling of a pale
but the lighting of a fire
Integrity is doing the right thing even
when no one is watching
the greatest mistake you can ever make
in life is to be continually fearing
that you will make a mistake
be like the flower that gives fragrance
even to the hand that crushes it
pay attention to your enemies they are
the first to discover your mistakes
if you don't turn your life into a story
you just become a part of someone else's
story
[Music]
courage isn't having the strength to go
on
is going on when you don't have the
strength
great minds discuss ideas average Minds
discuss events
small minds discuss people
[Music]
you cannot swim for New Horizons until
you have the courage to lose sight of
the shore
thanks for watching
which quote did you like the best tell
us in the comments below
[Music]